dr. Phil is in the 17th season of his
popular daytime talk show now in a new
podcast analysis of murder he's taking a
close look at infamous cases that
captivated the nation his first season
analyzes the story of Gypsy Rose
Blanchard she pleaded guilty to
second-degree murder in the stabbing
death of her mother DeeDee Blanchard
gypsy claims didi abused her for years
forcing her to have medical treatments
she did not need now she is asking for
an early release from prison dr. Phil
good morning good morning this is an
incredibly complicated case why did you
decide to make it the subject of a whole
podcast well because it is so camp so
complicated you know the mother here
clearly was Munchausen's by proxy and/or
factitious disorder imposed on another
as it's now called and this is a
disorder in the dsm-5
but I don't really think it should be I
think this is more abuse than a mental
illness and this woman had turned this
child into a cash cow and had done a
couple of dozen surgeries all unneeded
had her on a feeding tube or whole life
and the system had failed this young
girl it failed her doctors had
discovered this didn't follow up CPS had
been called a couple of times didn't do
anything just gave her back to the
abuser and it became apparent to this
young girl that look it's gonna be one
of us is gonna die it's either her it's
gonna be me the only way I escape is if
if she's dead you can make a case that
this is kind of self-defense but on the
other hand you can't condone vigilante
justice and it was a brutal is a brutal
murder Oodle not by her by someone she
met on the internet I mean her mother
subjected her more than 30 surgeries it
was yeah and and so but you interviewed
Gypsy Rose in prison what did you learn
from her I did and you see her in early
pictures where she looks you know tiny
and and she speaks in this squeaky voice
her mother had convinced her she had a
mental age of six or seven when I
interview her
she's an articulate young woman she
really had blossomed she said that she
felt less controlled and imprisoned in
prison than she did before she got there
she was very forthcoming and you know
she meets this guy on the internet and
everything starts rolling downhill from
there
luck of the draw what if she had met
someone that was a mental health
advocate or a normal human being that
had just said look I'm gonna call the
police we're gonna show up at your door
or something is going to happen here but
what I want to do and in these podcast
is take people inside the minds of these
killers so they understand how this
happens because you know people say to
me all the time dr. Phil who does this
kind of thing when they say that to me
it's not rhetorical they really mean who
does this kind of thing because we want
to know how to spot these predators we
don't know how to avoid these people we
want to know how to protect ourselves
and have you come up with a theory of
what happens with people are they kind
of normal people who just kind of slip
in a moment or is there some special
characteristic about these kind of
people that you're talking about you
know there are there are some
characteristics of these kind of people
and one is they grow up without empathy
for sure and you know you either have
empathy by about age seven or eight or
you don't and those people that are
sociopaths or Psychopaths or antisocial
personalities they're the one disorder
that tends to get worse in therapy
rather than better
oh that sounds because what they do is
they learn how to mimic the way they
should behave so oftentimes not always
but oftentimes they tend to get worse
because they learn okay here's how I
should behave yeah and it just makes
them more powerful dr. Phil thank you so
much episode one of dr. Phil's podcast
analysis of murder is available now and
we'll be right back